chaque année la grande distribution
jette un million trois cent
quatre-vingt-dix mille tonnes d'aliments
et des plus qu peuvent plus maintenir au
rio parce qu'ils sont défraîchis un cas
ce pillage fait dans l'indifférence
générale pendant des décennies des
aliments encore consommables mais dont
la date de péremption approche des
légumes ou des fruits un peuple et tri
des emballages abîmée tout y passe et
les poubelles débordent
mais après la crise de 2008 par
nécessité ou bien par conscience
citoyenne
certains s'indignent de toutes ces
denrées comestibles jetez moi le
gaspillage ça me scandalise pour ça
regardez ça enfin des fruits qui sont
parfaits mais magnifique alors par
altruisme mais aussi pour redorer le
blason de leur en scène certaines
grandes surfaces prennent l'initiative
de donner à des associations plutôt que
de jeter ses théories fier françoise
toute la nourriture qu'on jetait alors
que des gens meurent de race c'est vrai
que c'est
serviront des initiatives trop rare
selon le gouvernement qui met en place
une loi en 2016 contraignant toutes les
grandes surfaces à donner leurs invendus
à des associations
les députés ne veulent plus jamais voir
ça des containers pleins de nourriture
invendus aspergé de produits javellisant
hier soir ils ont voté un amendement au
projet de loi de transition énergétique
pour dire stop au gaspillage
les distributeurs n'auront plus le droit
de jeter
ils devront faire don de leurs surplus
mais malgré cette loi le gaspillage
perdure et ça avant même que les
produits n'arrivent dans les rayons en
cause les calibrages imposé par la
grande distribution aux producteurs
mille tonnes produites chaque année
mais dont 30% ne finiront pas sur les
étals des magasins
celles qui ne sont pas commercialisable
donc ce sont les petites tout ça
les petites pommes ce sont les pommes
qui ont des défauts voilà un défaut un
exemple type coincé uniquement une
friction d'une branche
aujourd'hui encore 3,3 pour cent des
produits vendus en supermarchés ont pour
destination la poubelle un chiffre que
tente de faire baisser le gouvernement
il s'est engagé à réduire de moitié le
gaspillage sur l'ensemble de la chaîne
alimentaire
[Musique]